برشلونه جل الحاضر وكل المستقبل والاوله
المرتجع لاستكمال بناء الدوله والمجتمع
فانني
اشيد بدورهم البطوله والمحور في نجاح
ثورتهم العظيمه منبه الى ان هنالك من
يتربص بهم ويحاول تدمير مستقبل بلادنا من
خلال ترويج السموم والمخدرات والافكار
المتطرفه وسطهم هو واجبنا جميعا مجابات
هذا الخطر مواطنين الكرام
لعلما انجز في السودان منذ فجرا لاستغلال
وحتى يومنا هذا يبقى دون مستوى الامل
والتطوعات الامر الذي يستدعي ويحتم علينا
جميعا ضروره التوحيد الصف والكلمه ويستلزم
التعاون والتوافق وان نتاهد على نفس
الكراهيه والعنف ونتخذ من الحوار
الجاد والموضوع وسيله لتجاوز الخلافات
والصراعات ونوحد الجبهه الداخليه
لمجابهه التحديات والمخاطر التي تحيط
بالوطن مواطنين الاوفياء تحل علينا هذه
الذكرى المجيده
وبلادنا تستشرف مرحله جديده لتطلع فيها
لتوسيع قاعده التوافق السياسي حتى يمهد
الطريق لخطوات اخرى مهمه لمناقشه وحصن
القضايا الجوهريه التي حددها الاتفاق
الايطالي لان ضعف جميعا
ومعايير تشكيل الحكومه وبرامج الانتقال
التي تهيئ البلاد للانتخابات العامه
لنهايه الفتره الانتقاليه المواطنين
الشرفاء جميعنا يدرك الظروف الاستثنائيه
التي تمر بها بلادنا
والتي تسببت في زياده المعاناه على معظم
قطاعات الشعب السوداني نحن نقدر هذه
المعاناه نشكر شعبنا على هذا الصبر
والصمود